foreign
's YouTube channel in today's session we
will try to learn how to update a table
in SQL but before we begin let me tell
you guys that we have daily updates on
multiple Technologies so if you're a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological Trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and don't forget to hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn now without further
Ado let's get started so how to update
table in SQL let's quickly take a look
on the syntax for today's function so
here we have the update keyword table
keyword and the table name which you
want to update and followed by that we
have the set keyword which will help
this equal to set a particular column
name to a new parameter to which you
want to update it now you're giving a
wear condition over here so where is the
keyword and the condition as a
user-defined condition and the
combination of where and condition will
help SQL to identify a particular Tuple
and update the parameter under that
particular condition now that we have
understood the syntax let's quickly get
back to the SQL IDE which is MySQL
workbench and try to execute a sample
command so we are on the IDE and
previously we tried to create an unplug
table so let's select the same table for
that let's use the database we created
that I simply learn
DB semicolon enter so we are on the
simply learn database now to update a
table we need to have some data in it so
as we remember we just try to create a
normal table in the previous session now
let's try to add some data into the same
table using the insert command so let's
try to make use of the insert command
and insert into is the keyword and plot
table is the table name and these are
the columns we have in the employee
table and followed by that we have the
values keyword and followed by that we
have the data which we need to enter
into the table and these items are in
the form of a tuple and every Tuple is
covered using parenthesis and inside the
tuples you have the first one which is
an integer type data which is as it is
and when you come into the text type
data they are covered using the single
quotes So let SQL identify that it is a
character type data now after entering
all the tuples separated by comma we
have a semicolon which indicates the end
of the statement now let's try to run
this particular statement and add the
data into the employee table so let's
select the database once again and now
let's try to add the data there you go
now we have the data added onto our
employer table let's quickly check the
employee table
select
start from
employee
there you go we have all the data added
onto the table employee ID employee name
and employee address let's say the last
employee Jeremy who's been working in
Delhi since a past couple of years and
you decide being the manager you decide
that he should be relocating to
Hyderabad and you need to update the
unplug table now by changing the
location of Jeremy from Delhi to
Hyderabad now let's try to run our
update query so first we have the update
keyword then employee
table
then
set
EMP address
equals to
Hyderabad
where
condition EMP
[Music]
ID
equals to
1 0 0 6 and semicolon so there you go
the code is complete we have the update
keyword followed by the table name then
set keyword to set that particular
column that is the employee address to
the key Hyderabad from Delhi we are
changing it to the Hyderabad which is
value or key by whichever you consider
and since it is a text type value we are
encoding it using the single quotes then
the where clause and the condition which
is employee ID must be equals to 1 0 0
6. now let's try to quickly run this
command
there you go now let's recheck if the
table has been updated or not so select
star from employee
table
let's run it
and there you go the last location
Jeremy which was Delhi is now updated to
Hyderabad so that's how you update
values in a table now with that we have
come to an end of this session and if
you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in this session do
let us know in the comment section below
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here